hi I'm Barton Seaver chef and National
Geographic fellow this is cook wise a
series in which we'll explore
sustainability community and
environmental issues through a universal
lens dinner every episode of cook wise
will take you on a sustainable adventure
we're going to visit some incredible
locations tell amazing stories and meet
some interesting people
my favorite part cook some delicious
food for me
dinner begins right here on the
Chesapeake Bay where I spent my summers
as a child walking up and down docks
pulling giant blue crabs right off the
pilings
later that night we've boiled them up in
it delicious crab boil with corn and old
bay just the spice of generations
there's nothing like it in the world but
unfortunately this world is changing I'm
sitting here in front of one of the very
last working water boats in East port
Maryland the fishing vessel wild country
now this is the kind of place I
absolutely love I want to introduce you
to the Mounties Pat junior and senior
these guys are making seafood work for
them in their own unique way thanks for
having me thank you the Mahoney's go out
crabbing every morning and sell
everything they bring back locally thank
you
they're literally cutting out the middle
making more money while taking less
crabs from the bay using time-honored
sustainable methods they are working the
waters to keep a family business and a
local tradition alive I've been looking
forward to this all day
now you finding people that your
customers like the connection they like
knowing seeing a face we have probably
love it comes off the boat that morning
and they're coming in here new steamer
right to their home hours after the
colloidal water well you can taste the
difference I'll tell you this meal
tastes just like my childhood I remember
this so clearly and it's a meal like
this Maryland crab boiled it really
connects us to the world the Chesapeake
Bay was once a major source of craft
that helped to feed the entire country
but overfishing habitat destruction and
pollution have brought these once
numerous delicacies to dangerously low
levels the decline and the gradual
recovery of the Chesapeake crab is a
story that's mirrored in fisheries all
over the globe there's something you can
do one meal at a time by supporting
responsible fishermen just like the
Mahoney's we can save our crabs and eat
them too for recipes tips techniques and
more information about our oceans visit
ocean National Geographic comm forward
slash cook wise to join us in a global
effort to protect the ocean go to I am
the ocean org and remember delicious is
the new environmentalism so cook wise
you